- Hello everyone, I am Priya Natarajan.
I am the current Director
of the Franke Program
in Science and the Humanities at Yale
and I'm an astrophysicist.
I am absolutely delighted
that you are all here
for the first convening of the year.
So, here's wishing everyone a
very happy and healthy 2021.
I want to mention that it
is hard not to celebrate
the recent shattering of a glass ceiling
that we all witnessed yesterday.
The swearing end of the
first female vice president
who is black and South Asian.
So, I just wanted to start
off by saying that despite
the pandemic and everything,
we don't know why this took so
long but we are so delighted
and proud to have this happen.
First, I would like to recognize
and thank Richard and Barbara Franke
who are here with us today
for the generous support
of the Franke Program
and many other events
and programs at Yale and we
are really happy to have you
participate so actively in
our programming as well.
So, before I tell you
about the exciting talk
we have in store today,
I wanted to remind you
that we are recording this event
and therefore all participants
must mute their videos.
And as for submitting questions,
please start sending them
as per usual to the chat.
And we have a slightly
altered format today
and I will mention that briefly.
So, we'll start off with the talk,
followed by sort of a brief
discussion and then the Q and A.
So today's talk, as you all know
is part of the ongoing
"Mapping as Knowing Series"
that we commenced a couple of years ago.
It was of course partly driven
by my own personal obsession
with mapping and cartography
but it turns out, it's a very,
very rich intellectual tool.
Mapping has been a very
important intellectual tool
to study more than just
mapping physical terrain.
The history of cartography is of course,
as we all know, very
deeply tied to the voyages
of exploration and colonial conquest.
However, these very tools
that created those maps
of domination can be used
today to understand better
the legacy of segregation and inequality
that they have left behind.
Our speaker today is an exemplary artist
who has managed just that.
Use maps to eliminate
geographies of segregation
to raise awareness of how these
divisions are deeply rooted
in our society, culture
and our daily lives
of where and they inform where we live.
Tonika Johnson, our speaker today
is a photographer social justice artists
and lifelong resident
of Chicago South side,
neighborhood of Englewood.
She's also co-founder of two
community-based organizations,
Englewood Arts Collective
and Residents Association
of Greater Englewood
which seek to reframe the
narrative of Southside communities
and mobilize people and
resources for positive change.
Within her artistic practice,
Tonika often explores urban
segregation and documents,
the nuance and richness
of the black community
countering pervasive media depictions
of Chicago's violence and crime.
As a trained photo journalist
and a former teaching artists,
she's been engaged in
building an artistic legacy
that has gained enormous
recognition in the last four years.
In 2017, she was recognized
by Chicago magazine
as a Chicago Award of the
Year for her photography
of Englewood's everyday beauty.
Her Englewood based photography projects
from the inside and everyday
rituals were exhibited
at Rootwork Gallery in Pilsen,
the Chicago Cultural Center,
the Harold Washington Library Center
and at Loyola University's Museum of Art.
Tonika is gonna be talking to us today
about her Folded Map Project
which visually investigates
the disparities among Chicago residents
who are map twins living
on opposite ends of streets
that span the city's
racial and economic divides
and brings them together
to have a conversation.
This project was also
exhibited at LUMA in 2018.
LUMA is a Loyola
University's Museum of Art.
Now, an excerpt of this
project is currently on display
at the museum of contemporary art
as part of the long dream exhibition.
Since 2018, Tonika has
transformed Folded Map
into an advocacy and
policy influencing tool
that invites audiences to
open a dialogue and question
how we are all socially impacted
by racial and institutional conditions
that segregate the city.
In 2020, she formalized
the Folded Map Project
into a nonprofit organization
where she serves as
the executive director.
She has won many awards and accolades,
I'll just name a few.
She was named one of
Field Foundations leaders
for New Chicago and was appointed
as a member of the
Cultural Advisory Council
for the Department of Cultural Affairs
and special events by
the Chicago City Council.
I'm delighted that after our talk,
we will follow it up with a
brief conversation with our own
resident cartographer, Bill
Rankin who is a faculty
in the Departments of the
History of Science and Medicine
who has worked extensively on
various uses of cartography
and whose most exciting
recent article was titled
and it's very relevant
to what what Tonika will
be telling us today.
It's titled "Race and the
Territorial Imaginary:
Reckoning with the Demographic Cartography
of the United States."
Following this, we open up for Q and A
and I just wanted to mention and thank Ty
for bringing Tonika and
the Folded Map Project
to my attention and to Tonika
for so graciously agreeing
to talk so promptly.
And we wanted to open the
series this year with her
so thank you so much Tonika
for being here and talking today.
Her work really exemplifies
this cross section
of what the between the sciences
and the humanities can do.
How the tools from science
and technology can be used
to understand and produce
deeper cultural meaning
and interrogate our
society and its values.
So, Tonika without much
further ado, here's onto you.
- Hi, thank you so much
for that amazing introduction and welcome.
I'm so delighted to be here with you all
and excited for you all to
view the Folded Map film
that I did create during the pandemic
so that I would be able
to have an opportunity
to engage with others
despite not being able to do
in-person presentation.
So, I'm really glad to
be here with you all
and excited to have the
conversation with you
after you view the Folded Map film.
- Great, thanks very
much, so I will go ahead
and Tonika, may I start?
- Yes.
(air whooshes)
I'm from South side, Chicago
Englewood neighborhood.
I'm sure the words you've heard
to describe Englewood include black,
dangerous, poor, gun violence.
However, Englewood is where
I grew up and still live.
Before I tell you about Folded Map,
I'd like you to think
about how you came to live
in the neighborhood that you grew up in
or where you live now, what
influenced your decision?
Who did you talk to?
And while you're thinking about that,
I'm gonna tell you how I
came to live in Englewood
and how I created the Folded Map Project.
It all started with my
grandmother, Marilyn G Tennie.
She came to Chicago
from down South in 1962
on the tail end of the Great Migration.
She wanted a better life, to
have a professional career
and she achieved it
when she came to Chicago
and got a job as an
administrative assistant
at the local Social Security office.
What black folks would call
'a good government job.'
For seven years, she saved her money
while working at the
Social Security office
to purchase a beautiful
two-flat brick building
on 62nd and Loomis in Englewood.
The building that I grew up in with my mom
and my two uncles.
My childhood was beautiful
unlike anything people
would imagine in Englewood.
I played outside every day, I
rode my bike with my friends,
I met my first friends in life,
one of them named Raymond.
Him and I would go to the
corner store every day
for cookies, pickles and chips.
Even my grandmother's
best friend, Ms. Patterson
lived right next door.
She had the same migration story.
Every summer, Ms. Patterson
would make homemade ice cream
and sell it to the kids for 25 cents.
It was also on this block
that I started high school.
(upbeat music)
I started going to Lane Tech High School.
And for those that don't know,
it's a selective enrollment high school,
15 miles north of Englewood.
And it's very diverse with a
student body of 4,000 students.
But everyday, I would have to
be at the bus stop by 5:45 AM
just to make it to
school by eight o'clock.
And on that every day commute,
I would look out the window
listening to my Walkman
and notice how my neighborhood
was very different
from the neighborhood that
my high school was in.
And this was in 1993, so there
was no GPS, no cell phones.
If you want it to go anywhere,
you had to know the address,
you had to know the streets.
And so, as I was on the
train going to school,
I would notice that my
neighborhood had vacant lots
and the neighborhood and Lane
Tech was in didn't have any.
My neighborhood had hundreds
of storefront churches
and there was none
in the neighborhood my high school was in.
My neighborhood had so
many beauty supplies stores
and I didn't see any up North.
And I would always wonder, "Why is that?"
And there's also one detail
that I paid extra attention to.
The streets.
I noticed that the streets were
named the same in Englewood
and also 15 miles North
in the neighborhood that
my high school was in.
Streets like Ashland,
Paulina, Wolcott and Western.
And even though those
streets named the same,
they looked completely different.
Ultimately, I want Folded
Map to help us heal
and get to know each other
so that we can tear down the
racist walls that divide us.
For more information, go
to foldedmapproject.com.
This is Tonika Johnson,
for the Folded Map Project.
(upbeat music)
- Okay, Tonika that was
brilliant and I think we can see
that the point that you are trying to make
is extremely powerful about how
we deal with systemic racism
is not by theorizing about
it but really look deeper
into our own personal
lives and lived experience.
And with something as ostensibly simple
as what you've shown us just addresses
that our twinned see how
different life experiences are
and the history of how that came to be.
I'm sure the city of New
Haven would be a place
that it would be fabulous to
have your project come to.
So, I wanted to share the
link that you can all...
Tonika, do you wanna tell us
what people can download from the website?
- Yes, so, Priya you'll share the link.
- Yeah, I just-
- Okay, perfect.
So, the link that Priya
is sharing with you
is a link to the latest
expansion of Folded Map
which is the Folded Map action kit.
The contact list for Folded
Map over the past three years
has grown to include 800 people
who all wanted to meet their map twins.
And since I knew I wasn't going to be able
to actually facilitate
all of those meetings,
it allowed me to create a way for people
to have their own self guided experience
as close as possible to kind
of walking through the shoes
of a resident in their
map twin neighborhood.
And so, the action kit
includes information
about the project as
well as the participants,
neighborhoods, so you can see
the statistical difference
from economics, education,
business corridor, housing
and then it also invites you to describe
your own neighborhood to answer
the questions of Folded Map
and then to actually go run errands
in your map twin neighborhoods.
So, the errands is an invitation
one to go visit another
neighborhood but also an opportunity
to kind of disrupt the stereotypes
that have been embedded in Chicago
and heads of other neighborhoods.
So in order to do that,
I figured that just go run
errands in another neighborhood.
You'll really be able
to not only meet people
in that neighborhood or who
are doing the exact same thing,
basic things that we all do
but you'll also be able to understand
how different it is and
what disparity looks like.
How convenient it is, or
how inconvenient that it is.
So, in addition to instructing
people to do these errands,
I'm also inviting them to
share back their experience
in the Folded Map Action Kit workbook,
which is a very simple workbook.
We just want you to
share what you thought.
How was the experience?
And you can upload that
on to Folded Maps website.
So, we have the link that Priya sent
where you can fill out and
get a beautiful hard copy
that was designed by my fellow artist,
graphic designer friend from Englewood
and you can receive it in the mail
or if you have enough ink in your printer,
you can go to the website
and print it out yourself.
So, it's up to you
but that is the one of the
latest expansions of Folded Map.
- Thank you so much Tonika,
that sounds really, really exciting.
And wouldn't it be wonderful if every city
and every town in the country did this?
- Yeah, so after creating
the Folded Map Action Kit,
a few people who I know from
other States, other cities,
of course mostly, Midwestern cities
since we are like the
legacy segregation cities.
They wanted to adapt it to
their city and so right now,
I'm working with my Folded
Map partner, Dr. Maria Krysan
to create, "Find Your Fold."
We're just trying to raise
money to actually create
this other action kit that
will be hopefully available
for free for other people
who want to do Folded Map
in their own city.
We want people to understand
that Chicago has a unique grid map
that affords us the opportunity to compare
in a very unique way but every
place that has segregation
has a divide and that divide is your fold.
And so, if you just get people
from those different sides
to have a conversation,
then you can do Folded
Map in your own city.
So, I'm currently working
on that right now.
- Great, That sounds fab.
So, I'm delighted to have Bill on now.
Bill, are you on, could you
turn your video on please?
- Okay, hello everyone, thanks.
So, Tonika this is fantastic.
It's so great to see this.
So, I'm gonna share this here.
So, this is the map that
I made about 10 years ago
that obviously you've seen.
I wanna start just by
answering the questions
that you pose to all of us.
How did I come to live
in the place that I live?
So, in the late 1960s, my dad
lived at 7,800 South Saginaw
which is down here on the map.
And then in 1970, he was
with his own folded map twin
and moved up to the Northern Suburbs
which is where I was born.
And the stories that I hear
from him about why that happened
was, the neighborhood was changing
and the South side was mixed
when he would move there in the sixties
and was becoming much less mixed.
Obviously, it's now not mixed at all.
And he wanted to have a home
that he could stay in forever,
have kids, et cetera and
that's my story of Chicago.
And then the weirdest map came from,
I thought also was kind of speaking
to some of what you're
you're talking about.
Actually, I heard from a school teacher
in the suburbs of Chicago
and he had done a
project with some of his,
I think seventh graders
trying to understand Chicago
and the way he had done that
as to try to make some maps,
trying to understand exactly the things
you were talking about.
Where are their stores?
Where are the jobs?
How long does it take
people to get to work?
And so, they had found
all these statistics.
Some from the census, some from the city
about the kinds of things
you're talking about
and they'd made a bunch of maps of them.
And the one map that just wasn't working
was the map of race.
They just couldn't make a map
that they could really make much sense of.
And all the maps that
they had been making,
all the maps that I had seen myself
looked like this one in the bottom left
where you shaded every
neighborhood a solid color
and it certainly showed you
places like the South side
and the West side but it
didn't really give you a sense
of how stark the segregation really was.
- Yes.
- And so the map
that you see here that
with all the little dots
is what I came up with in my conversations
with this middle school teacher as a way
to getting kids in the
suburbs to understand
just how stark the divisions were
and just how removed their own lives were
from the vast majority of
people that live in the city.
And it's really great for
me to see you making use
of the same map in your project.
- So, have you made the map,
'cause I was searching for it.
I was like, "Oh my gosh, does this exist?"
And lo and behold, I found your map.
(chuckles)
- That's great.
What I love about the map
actually is how many people
I hear from from Chicago.
So, it's not just people who
are interested in mapping
in general, but people
in Chicago in particular
and people want me to talk
to people in the schools,
they want to put this in
some exhibition somewhere,
and it's about doing work on
the city of Chicago exactly.
And the other thing-
- You and I
definitely have to link up and partner.
(both laugh)
- Yeah, it'd be great.
And then, there's this
map that I actually made
when I moved to New Haven.
And it was a way of just
trying to understand
what was going on
in the place that I was
going to be living in,
and how did I come to
live in that place I live?
I live in this mostly
but not all pink area
right around here in East Rock.
And a lot of it was actually
not so much talking to people
and getting nudged by realtors
and that kind of stuff.
It was looking up where
the restaurants were,
where the cafes were,
where could I live close to work and walk
and those kinds of things.
(indistinct chatter)
- I lived in the same neighborhood
and for me, the main criterion
was, can I walk to work?
- Yeah, yeah and can I walk to a cafe?
I used like Thai food,
can I find Thai food?
I really like Thai food.
And so it was those questions that led me
to really confront the
segregation in New Haven
because the kinds of things
that I thought were important
in my life were the things that existed
in the predominantly white neighborhoods
instead of the other neighborhoods.
- Wow.
- Mostly it's saying thank
you Tonika for that project,
really great.
And yeah, I'm really glad
to be able to share that far and wide now.
- Yeah, now this is amazing
and I definitely would
love to partner with you
on Find Your Fold 'cause I
definitely would need some maps
for other cities that
I've gotten requests from
(chuckles)
so I'll be emailing you.
- That's great, that's great.
- And then, we would love to
have a high resolution copy
of your New Haven map.
We would like to frame it and
make it available to everyone.
I'm getting requests
on the chat right now.
- Yeah, yeah, I'm going
to send a link in the chat
actually I saw that too.
It's on my website.
It's already up in I
think full resolution.
- And good quality, fantastic.
- Yeah, yeah, I'll send
the link real quickly.
- Oh, I think Carla already shared it.
- [Bill] Okay, great.
- [Tonika] Oh, good.
(Tonika chuckles)
- [Bill] Great, great.
- So, yeah, sorry.
Tonika, thanks for the pandemic,
we could actually host you in person
but now there are plenty
of reasons for you.
You've already seen the map
so I hope you are going
to be enticed to come
when you are able.
- Yes, I would love to
and especially since
my work with Folded Map
has informed my current
project that I'm working on
that will probably be within the...
still working on within the next year
but of course when you
talk about segregation
and people in migration, you
eventually land at real estate
and you eventually land
at all of the issues
that we talk about with home ownership
and so my current project is
focusing on making more public
in an interactive way, the
history of land sale contracts
and how they played a significant role
in the current economic
state of Greater Englewood.
And it kind of all
started with the question
of when was Greater
Englewood's home ownership
rate ever higher?
because it's currently like 23%.
And trying to find the
answer to that question
as well as meeting amazing
people doing wonderful research
led me to the information
about land sale contracts
specifically in Greater Englewood.
So, that is what my next
project will be focusing on.
My goal is to make landmarkers
for the homes that are still
existing in Greater Englewood
that was sold land sale contracts
and of course, most of them
are vacant or demolished
so it's a direct connection
to that kind of discriminatory practice.
- I'm sharing another map here.
I did this for a local newspaper
of New Haven independent number years ago
and there was a local nonprofit here
who had a bunch of really
good data about foreclosures
in New Haven and we did this
map to kind of push back
against some of the narratives happening
with the foreclosure crisis
that we're highlighting
and centering the stories of
of white middle class families.
And of course there,
their stories were serious
and for sure but the vast
majority of actual foreclosures
were happening in communities of color.
And so, I completely agree
that the maps of segregation
and racial segregation
and the maps of housing
inequality are the same map.
- Yeah, and it really became clear to me
how maps are such a powerful
tool in demonstrating
so many layers of disparity
which is why I partnered with UICs,
GIS department to create
an interactive mapping tool
on Folded Maps website where
you can layer the schools
that are quality, the
businesses that are different
on the North and South sides
because it becomes even more clear
when you start to add
those specific layers
so I really appreciate the map you made
about the foreclosures because
a lot of people don't know
how they disproportionately
affect black neighborhoods.
- Okay, great.
I think there are lots of questions
that are coming in on the chat.
So Ty, did you wanna-
- Sure, thank you so much.
So, a compliment first to her project
and the question
(inaudible)
what sort of divides you
might find in the suburbs.
- Oh, wow.
Yeah, I actually want
to expand the project
to include maps wins from the suburbs
'cause there's so many ways
to kind of do that kind of map twinning
because streets that
are in Chicago do exist
in the Northern Suburbs that
are predominantly white.
But even if I was just to
compare the Northern Suburbs
to the Southern Suburbs,
you would see the same
kind of disparities.
The Southern suburbs
they are now turning
more, predominantly black.
they used to be white.
And so you're seeing the
same kinds of disparities
specifically with the
quality of the education
and the values of the homes.
So, those are the most noticeable ones
but of course there are many others.
Of course, taxes.
(chuckles)
Once you peel back all
of the other layers,
you'll see that difference as well.
- Could you talk a bit
more about the taxes
and what you found there?
- Well, I'm still in the process
of learning and researching
but there's definitely a
significant difference.
What is most interesting
is that within the city,
they're actually black neighborhoods,
the taxes are lower but
compared to their homes,
it's actually higher given everything
that costs more in the neighborhoods.
So, just the cost of living
is surprisingly more expensive
in the poor neighborhoods
and everything that affects
the increase of taxes
puts people in a position to be displaced
and so that's a whole
‘nother project in itself
and I'm still reading and learning a lot
about what influences and
what impacts all of that.
So, feel free to share with
me anything you all find,
email me because I'm
definitely diving into that
especially with my land
sale contract project.
- Great, yes.
I know that in New Haven,
there is a history of over assessment
in particularly Latino areas
over assessment of homes
perhaps, it's disturbing a thing
but on the premise that
the residents there
would not have the money
to hire real estate experts
and attorneys to go and challenge.
(indistinct)
- It's so many ways in which
it's kind of discriminatory.
What's happening now
specifically in Chicago
is that a lot of homeowners of color,
people are buying, are paying their taxes,
ultimately buying their taxes
and they have to not only fight to recover
that but they have to stay
on top of paying their taxes
because people just predatory,
they wait for people to just be late
and so Black and Brown
neighborhoods are subject to that.
- Yap, there is a question
from one of the participants.
Perhaps Bill, could you
show the Chicago map again?
There might be a question forthcoming.
And then in the meantime,
while he's pulling that up,
what artists activists do you admire?
- Oh my gosh, so many.
(chuckles)
Their names escape me right now.
I can't remember her name but
the artists who did the edits
of the New York Times articles, Alexandria
I think it's Bale and we
pasted them across the city
showing the difference between how stories
that have black subjects are covered
and worded very differently
than stories that have white subjects,
specifically crime related stories.
And she did the edits and
the rewrites and showed how,
and blocked out certain words
so that people could see
very much like Folded Map.
The actual difference in how
the subjects were described.
And so, she's one that
I have been following
and in amazement for a couple of years.
There is an artist in New Orleans,
her name is Shana Griffin.
She has a project called "Displaced"
and it focuses on utilizing maps
but showing the economic
centers of New Orleans
and how they are connected
to where slaves were sold.
And so, that was fascinating to me
to see the direct correlation
between the financial centers
in New Orleans and how it's connects
to the history of slavery
and selling slaves
and how those exact locations
became the financial
districts of New Orleans.
So, that's an amazing project
that I have been noting out
for a long time now and
using as inspiration.
But I have to think about the other ones
'cause so many names come to mind.
Thank you for the question though.
- There was a request to
see that map again here.
I'm just gonna share it briefly
but I'll stop sharing so
you can see Tonika again.
- [Tonika] Amazing.
- So Bill, I had a
question about that map.
Was all that data
publicly available to you
or was it a bit of-
- Oh yeah, its all public?
So the census data you
can get from the web
at the time I got it from
the Census Bureau website
which is pretty clunky.
Now it's much easier the
National Historical GIS, NHGIS.
I'll put this in the chat as well.
nhgis.org
So, it's really easy to get census data
and then I got a bunch of
data from the City of Chicago
as well about parks and cemeteries
and those kinds of things.
And then the real work of the map
was just really figuring
out where people didn't live
'cause if you just plot all the
data in kind of big buckets,
the dots spread out everywhere
but once you start figuring
out where people don't live,
where the industrial districts are
and the shipping and the cemeteries
and those kinds of things,
then you really start to
see the real separations
between the neighborhoods
really pop into place.
But yeah, I know all the data's free
and I found the web and I think
it really underscored for me
how getting a totally
different sense of the city
isn't necessarily always
about better data.
It's about taking the data you have
and doing something
really different with it
using dots instead of solid dots.
- Right, I'm reading off the chat.
Somebody had a question that inspired me
to ask this question.
Wouldn't it be really revealing
to overlay on top of this COVID cases
and COVID fatalities, to layer on.
So, Tonika is this something
that you're thinking about right now?
- Actually very early in the pandemic,
I anticipated that disparity
and I transformed my Instagram page
from being my personal
account to my platform
to share all of this
information in the pandemic
and so I did have Instagram posts,
I'm not a cartographer in the
sense that I make the maps
but that was a dream of mine to overlay
because I did have a set of three posts
that showed Chicago segregation
in the fifties, sixties,
and then the Chicago school closures
that were also different
and then ultimately the
Chicago map of the COVID cases.
And it's very clear and
evident the disparity
but I did that probably in May.
I showed all three of those maps together
so people could see consistently
where the disinvestment
and disparity was really showing
or having a negative impact.
- I'm gonna share, again,
this is from a page from a PDF
made by the one of the local
unions here in New Haven.
So, you'll see my map of
foreclosures in the upper left
and then the map of
COVID in the lower right,
and it's the same pattern.
It's really, really amazing.
And just putting those side by side
with the same kinds of graphics,
I think makes that point
really, really powerful.
But the COVID map is not mine.
- And what I have also been
to, I was just sharing the link
to the two artists that
I've mentioned in the chat.
What I've been thinking about lately
especially if you will,
the reckoning of 2020,
the fact that people are using
are saying systemic racism,
are talking about
segregation and red lining
in more public mainstream media
and that has never happened before.
I have been encouraging
people to understand
that listening and really
recognizing the impact
of all of these issues on black lives
will afford our country the
opportunity to understand
how all of the sectors,
all of the sectors in
our country are impacted
by racism and ultimately capitalism.
But those go hand in hand and
it's the lives and experiences
of black people that can
really show that connectivity,
how it is in each of those
industries and sectors
and so there's value beyond
just having a conscience
and valuing black lives.
But if we are interested in working
towards a more fair country,
more equitable country,
you can do that through the
recognition and understanding
of how all of those
things impact black lives.
- And I think the visual
argument is so much more powerful
than even the verbal.
- Yeah.
- It is just so stark
and so visible and compelling, right.
There's a way in which it is built.
Wouldn't you say that is
one of the power of maps.
- Oh, he has to get unmuted.
I know
(laughs)
you have to wait for that.
- That's right, that's right.
But for me thinking back
to when I made that map
for the first time,
I think a lot of the
especially growing up,
the South side was an idea.
It was a nebulous place
that I didn't even know
quite where it was or how big it was.
And what I found making the map
was that it really became
much more of a real place.
And I start to see lots
of other places too
that I'd never heard about.
So, like you Tonika, I didn't
know much about the West side.
The South side was the sort of the thing
that everybody talked about.
And then there's also black
neighborhoods outside in Cicero,
I never even knew
that there was a black
neighborhood in Cicero.
And so maps kind of have
a strong visual argument
that shows the segregation,
they also make it really
specific and they make it real.
They kind of anchor it in actual places
in a way that I think did
much more powerful work for me
than talking in coded language
about the inner city
or even the South side
which has its own kind of
coded language in Chicago.
- Yes, when you talk about
geography in Chicago,
you're talking about people.
That's what it means in Chicago.
- Further questions, the first,
New Haven was split up by the highways,
is this true in Chicago?
- Yes,
(chuckles)
Yes.
Just to answer directly without
tracing back the history,
yes, indeed.
Yes, indeed.
- So, it's very deliberate as the point
because highways were planned.
They're very planned.
I think that's what noting
the intentionality...
(speaks faintly)
- Second question from Professor Wechsler.
I think it's really important to you.
She says that there is a
generational aspect to this film.
How are you thinking of
showing the history on the map?
- Oh, interesting.
Well, I'm first and foremost
starting with the personal
because in order for the
history to even become valuable,
people have to understand
the present day impact
and that you can do intergenerationally.
And starting with that,
then the connection to
the history can be made.
So, I am actually in the process
of creating curricular
resources or using Folded Map
as a curricular resources for
teachers in Social Science
and in Art where the students can examine
their own environment first
and then use that as an entree
into being connected to the
historical forces decisions
that have influenced
their present day life.
So, that is the route I'm taking
in developing the Folded Map curriculum
and those are the ways in which teachers
and educators have been using
it to help their students
understand the history of segregation.
I hope that hits
- For the questions in the chat,
Priya, could you have anything else?
- No, I was just going to ask Tonika,
was it photography that first got you,
as you talked about in the film,
that you sort of you understood
what your trip to your school
was about in terms of the
change in the landscape
but I was curious about
how you got to photography
as a medium as an artist.
- Oh, yes and I'll answer that.
I just saw Laura's clarification
to her question pop up.
She was talking about inter
personal within the family.
So, in regards to Folded Map
and connecting it to family history,
that's also a part of using
it as a curricular resource.
Having students ask their parents,
ask their their grandparents
the very same question
that I pose to everyone,
how did you come to live
either in the neighborhood or in the city?
So, teachers have definitely
made that an assignment
for students to ask their parents
how did they come to
live in this neighborhood
and then to also ask their grandparents.
So, interviewing techniques
have definitely been applied.
But Priya to go to your question,
how I got introduced to photography.
Really, my family
specifically my maternal side
and my grandmother as
well she's an artist.
And my mom is a writer, a poet,
my uncles that I grew up with,
they're also visual artists.
So, art was just valued
so much in my home.
I often joke with people
that it was valued so much
that when I decided that
I was interested in music,
my grandmother and my
mom bought me a piano.
(chuckles)
And I didn't even stick
with piano for that long.
Maybe like five, six
years but I had a piano.
So, they really art
and so when my mom and my dad were married
and we were living together,
my father had a fascination for cameras.
He never evolved into being
a professional photographer
but I grew up around a
camera in my face so much
that it sparked a curiosity
in me very early on to use it.
So, by the time I was in eighth grade,
I was already kind of
fascinated with with cameras
and then taking pictures,
so that's how it evolved.
- Anyway, that sounds fabulous.
But before I say, thank you.
I just wanted to check in that
Richard and Barbara Franke
are old residents of Chicago,
so, Barbara, do you have
any particular question
and Ty could you unmute Barbara please?
- Yeah, I'm trying to unmute her now.
There we go.
- Yes. I'm very curious
it's fascinating to me
but I'm also very curious
there is an exodus
from the black community
to return to the South.
Do you think some of the
questions that you have used
Tonika, for your project would also relate
to those who are leaving?
- Yes, definitely.
It's interesting that
you're bringing that up
because as a 41 year old black
lifetime resident of Chicago,
I definitely can refer to the
exoduses of black Chicago.
15, 20 years ago, I definitely
remember my age group
talking about moving to Atlanta.
It was a huge exodus of
black Chicagoans my age
at that time moving to Atlanta,
then Texas, Austin, now North Carolina
and it mostly dealt with
not only just home ownership
or the lack of housing
stock in black neighborhoods
and how overpriced houses
were in other neighborhoods
that ended that ultimately
unpredominantly why in Chicago
but the lack of amenities and resources
and how difficult it is to live close
to where you probably will be working
and all of those decisions
to all of those elements
as well as the continuation of schools
in black neighborhoods
being closed and going down
in quality as a result
of the population loss.
All of that together made it
bleak for young black families
in Chicago which up added
to them seeking opportunity
in that reverse migration down South.
They can take their Chicago
salaries, their education
and just have a better quality
of life and get a larger home
in some of those Southern
cities and States,
and it's still kind of happening now.
- Are there any other questions?
If not, let's all give
Tonika big round of applause,
virtual applause.
(claps)
- Thank you all so much.
(chuckles)
- Thank you so much Tonika
for a fantastic talk
and what a brilliant project.
Yeah.
- Thank you.
- Thanks for taking the time
to share it with us.
- No problem.
- I look forward
to seeing you in person.
- Oh yes, definitely and
until then, feel free.
If you all are on Instagram, I live there.
So follow me, it's Tonika J.
I share a lot of the information
that I come across on social
media as well as emailing me
through Folded Map, the
website if you have questions
or requests and also to
download the action kit
if you'd like or sign up
to receive a hard copy.
- Thank you so much Bill
as well for being part
of this wonderful event today.
- Yes, thank you so much Bill.
- [Bill] Yeah, I'm glad I
could be here, this is great.
- I'm going to email you so-
- I thought it.
(both laugh)
(indistinct)
- Perfect.
- [Bill] All right.
- So, I just wanted to
close and remind you all
of two upcoming events.
One is an event that we are co-sponsoring
and that is with the
Yale Quantum Institute.
It's a reading by Ben Okri
was Nigerian-British a writer
who has written wonderful
set of short stories
that I heard him read in
London couple of nights,
seems like many years ago
now, on Quantum Mechanics.
So, I invite you to that.
And then, our next talk
in the Distinguished Speaker
Series is our very own
Marc Brackett, will be
speaking on February 18.
So, we'll send you all
information and the posters.
Till then, stay well and by everyone.
And thanks once again Tonika, Bill and Ty
Bye